there have been about nine major Wars
that have been predicted in the last 25
years but interestingly none of them
have escalated to the level of a major
regional war or a global conflict that
we would describe as a world war 3 and I
think a lot of it has to do with the
fact that we are not just interdependent
in terms of trade because as we all know
Britain and Germany traded a fair bit
with each other prior to World War 1
breaking out a hundred years ago but not
only do we have trade intra pendens
today today we have a large amount of
financial integration we hold a lot of
each other's debt in terms of Treasury
bonds corporate bonds we are very
invested in each other's economies there
is also supply chain dispersal we now
manufacture goods in even our own rivals
countries the United States and the
Soviet Union didn't trade a whole lot
with each other today not only do the
United States and China trade a great
deal with each other but many American
goods are of course made in China
Walmart America's largest retailer makes
most of its goods in China if a war
between the US and China were to
suddenly break out tomorrow that would
probably mean very bad news for the
bottom line of America's largest
retailer so we are much more careful of
course about stumbling into conflict
because we not only have nuclear
deterrence of course and we have the
lessons of the past those are all
intellectual factors and strategic
factors we also have the trade
independence we also have the financial
integration we also have the supply
chain dispersal and we have the allure
of the size of the markets of our rivals
and competitors most of the American
fortune 500 generates more revenues from
abroad than from home it doesn't want to
fight wars with the countries on which
it depends for its exports and for its
revenues leaders are wisely making these
cost-benefit calculations and saying yes
I have national pride at stake yes I
believe that my country has been
aggrieved historically by this rival yes
we want to win in the relationship with
in the race with them but we want to do
all of those things but it's not worth
the price of actually going into all-out
warfare I wish that our institutions
were to embed this kind of integration
and wisdom that prevents a World War 3
from breaking out we always have to be
afraid that that can happen and all of
those things that we're doing correctly
the supply chain dispersal the financial
integration the trade interdependence
even the demographic into integration
between countries let's do a lot more of
that